hablar de una realidad lamentable en el
deporte de alto rendimiento en venezuela
se trata de los impagos que hay por
parte de las instituciones de ese país
con los atletas y también de los
entrenadores tenemos una denuncia
exclusiva zee de raúl en este caso vamos
a hablar de la denuncia de viácheslav
kalinichenko quien es entrenador de
atletismo ucraniano y dirige a la
venezolana robelis peinado ella practica
el salto con garrocha santo con pértiga
y fue bronce en el mundial de 2017 en la
que fue la primera medalla para
venezuela en la historia de esta
competición es una de las pocas figuras
latinoamericanas que integra la élite de
esta disciplina
vyacheslav entrena robelis desde
diciembre de 2015 a través de un
contrato con la federación venezolana de
atletismo y cuenta que durante la
mayoría de ese tiempo los impagos han
sido una constante ahora mismo le deben
20 mil 300 euros
voltereta voltear a félix dinero está
dominado este es el sexto año que robe
el y se entrena conmigo y solo me
pagaron durante un año actual que el
windows watch ver en realidad durante
seis o siete meses recibí una buena
transferencia de dinero para su bien y
es la carta expulsión brasero
ecuatorianas y bilis después empezaron
con los retrasos con las promesas yo
compraba los tiquetes con mi dinero los
cuales tampoco me pagaron línea
ecuatorial nietos
chile
juanes que estamos hablando de una
cantidad importante de dinero la que le
deben a viatcheslav que dice él cuando
reclama lo que le deben a las
autoridades del deporte venezolano según
versa se habla la federación venezolana
de atletismo lo remitía el ministerio de
deporte y el ministerio le decía que su
pago lo manejaba la federación pero
siempre le daban largas ese entrenador
asegura que le llegaron a deber cien mil
euros para 2010 y nueve años de los
juegos panamericanos de lima ahí le
empezaron a entregar nuevas condiciones
para sus pagos
y luego empezaron a decir cuando robelis
el tren y más le pagaremos y cuando no
entrene no le pagaremos y hasta en eso
estuve de acuerdo pensé bueno no voy a
discutir al respecto
ella estaba en venezuela y yo le escribí
a los planes los entrenamientos ese
trabajo también se hacía también se
estaba llevando a cabo
ahora rovelli se va a mudar a italia
para entrenar con un entrenador italiano
pero yo pensé que si ella se va a mudar
italia entonces el ministerio y la
federación no entregarán nada y cerraran
el asunto y por eso decidí contar mi
verdad y tacto de sacro eterna y ariel y
cuando escuchamos precisamente esta
última parte donde bh eslava teme ahora
que su pupila encuentre a otro entrenado
entrenador y que esta deuda nunca se
salte qué va a pasar
raúl esa es una de las razones que ha
llevado a viatcheslav a hacer esta
denuncia nos contó que no es el único
que pasa por este tipo de situaciones
habla también de iván pedroso el
entrenador de yuri ma rojas vigente
campeona olímpica y récord del mundo en
triple salto la gran estrella del
deporte venezolano
el próximo bajo se sitúa usted le está o
no hay otra situación muy similar en
venezuela con un entrenador de esgrima
muy reconocido y maravilloso si chocas
con ayer
si tocas con
y su situación es similar
tampoco le pagan utiliza su propio
dinero para patrocinar a los alumnos le
pagan de vez en cuando nos escribimos y
nos hablamos y a veces le pagan con
sam's beijing
y cuando saltaba a pedroso también tuvo
problemas con el pago eso los edificios
a grabar yanina game a player
cuando yo no saltaba tanto hace unos
cinco años pero todos los entrenadores
tienen problemas en venezuela de eso no
hay duda todos los amigos me hablan de
es una edad
no
estaba atrincherado en esto de leyes
apartamos todo
que triste juan está en un cielo que
ocurre dentro del deporte venezolano de
alto nivel con nuestros atletas
venezolanos que dicen desde el
ministerio de deporte contactamos tanto
al ministerio deporte como la federación
venezuela no en el atletismo para pedir
su versión acerca de estos impagos de
los que nos hablas vyacheslav pero no
obtuvimos ninguna declaración al
respecto recordemos que sabíamos un caso
muy similar hace poco fue la denuncia
que hizo el año pasado josé peseiro ex
seleccionador de fútbol de venezuela a
quien le llegaron a deberse con el 14
meses de salario y terminó abandonando
el cargo como decía vyacheslav esto no
es un caso aislado y que por supuesto
esta ventana de france de 4 se mantiene
abierta para cuando así lo disponga el
gobierno venezolano y las autoridades
deportes para dar su versión sobre esta
denuncia